As we discussed
earlier-- even if we
have multiple
observations we can still
find the structure of the best
linear estimator in a fairly
simple, computational
way-- by solving
a system of linear equations.
But usually, we do not get
nice and simple formulas.
But here is a nice
example, in which
we will get a simple formula.
The example is
something that we have
seen before-- in various guises.
We're trying to estimate a
certain quantity-- Theta.
And what we obtain is multiple,
noisy observations of Theta.
That is-- at each observation
we see Theta plus a noise term.
The assumptions that
we make is that Theta
has a prior distribution
with a certain mean
and a certain variance.
And the noise terms
are zero mean--
but they have some variance.
And the additional
assumption that we make
is that all of these
random variables
are independent of each other.
So the noise terms
are independent
between themselves-- and also,
the noise terms are independent
of Theta.
This is the usual
assumption-- but actually--
in the linear
estimation problem,
we do not need to make an
independence assumption.
It's enough for our
purposes to just assume
that they are uncorrelated.
So we will assume that the
correlation coefficient
between any two of these random
variables is equal to zero.
Now we can write down the form
of the mean squared estimation
error criterion that
we have-- and try
to find good choices
for the coefficients
to be attached to each
one of the observations.
However-- we're going
to find the solution
to this problem using
a shortcut that's
going to bypass all
kinds of computations.
Here's the trick.
Let us suppose-- in addition--
that these random variable were
not just uncorrelated,
but independent.
And that they happen to be
normal random variables.
This is a problem that
we did study before--
and we did find the maximum
a posteriori probability
estimate of Theta.
Because the
posterior was normal,
and we found that this was also
the conditional expectation
estimator of Theta.
And we did find a formula for
it-- which took this form.
This was the form of the
optimal estimate of Theta.
If you obtain values for
the different observations--
little xi.
On the other hand-- if
you want to translate this
into random variable notation--
then notice that this is going
to be a random variable,
this is our estimator.
it's a conditional
expectation of Theta given X--
and it's random
because it depends
on the values of the data that
we see-- which are themselves
random variables.
On the other hand--
this x0-- is actually
the prior mean of Theta.
So this is a constant--
it's not random,
and that's why we keep it
with a lowercase notation.
Now-- what is interesting
about this form?
It is a linear function
of the observations.
And as we have discussed
earlier-- if it turns out
that the conditional expectation
is linear in the observations,
then this is also the best
possible linear estimator.
So for the special case--
where our random variables are
independent and normal--
we have a formula
for the best linear estimator.
Now what if they are not normal?
Suppose that they're not normal.
But that they have the same
means and variances as here--
as in the normal example.
Since these means and
variances are the same--
and since these random
variables are uncorrelated--
it follows that also
all kinds of covariances
between the random
variable is involved here--
are going to be the same
as for the normal example.
Now, the optimal solution to
the linear estimation problem--
as we discussed
earlier-- only cares
about the means,
variances, and covariances
of the random
variables involved.
The details of the
distribution do not matter.
So whether we have
normal distributions--
or non-normal distributions--
as long as we're
making enough assumptions that
fix all the means, variances,
and covariances of
interest-- we should
be getting exactly
the same solution.
Therefore-- this
solution remains valid
for the case of general
random variables, as well.